russia's president vladimir putin's
claim to victory over mario paul has
been rejected by u.s president joe biden
he says there is no evidence that the
ukrainian port city has completely
fallen
new satellite images appear to show mass
graves near mariupol ukrainian officials
have accused russia of burying up to 9
000 dead civilians there in an effort to
conceal the slaughter taking place in
the city mario paul's last remaining
holdout is the azov style
steel plant where some 2000 ukrainian
soldiers and 1 000 civilians are
believed to be holed up
here's a closer look at that vast
industrial complex that has become a
symbol of ukrainian resistance
the huges of style steel plant seen here
in footage from russian state television
ukrainian forces are holding out inside
mario paul has witnessed nearly two
months of heavy fighting with much of
the strategic port in ruins president
putin has claimed a victory in the city
and told his defence minister to seal
off this last stronghold
i consider the proposed storming of the
industrial area pointless i order to
abort it
there is no need to climb into these
catacombs and crawl underground through
these industrial facilities
block off this industrial area
so that not even a fly can get through
but in washington u.s president joe
biden dismissed putin's
it's
claims
whether he does control mario paul one
thing for sure we know about mario paul
he should allow humanitarian carters to
let people on that steel mill and other
places are buried under rubble to get
out
ukrainian authorities have also urged
moscow to open humanitarian corridors to
allow those sheltering in the heavily
bombarded azov stole plant to flee these
pictures were filmed by the far-right
nationalist ukrainian group as of
battalion defending the plant the
footage shows some of the hundreds of
civilians said to be sheltering in the
bunkers below the steel works
but previous efforts to organize
evacuations from mariupol have had
little success
some one hundred thousand residents are
thought to be still living among the
ruins
but the dead may lie elsewhere
mariupol's mayor has accused russian
forces of hiding the true death toll by
burying bodies of mariupol residents in
a neighboring town
u.s satellite company maxar released
photos which it says show new mass
graves in manhush west of mario poll
attempts to broker a ceasefire ahead of
the orthodox easter festival this
weekend failed
unfortunately russia rejected a proposal
to establish an easter ceasefire
this demonstrates very well how the
leaders of that state actually feel
about the faith about one of the most
joyful and important religious holidays
but we maintain hope hope for peace
but from the azov style steel plant
hopes for peace seem far away the
blockaded ukrainian fighters say they do
not plan to surrender
and there's growing concern that those
trapped inside could starve
well dw correspondent rebecca ritters is
in kiev and i asked her for an update
from mario paul and who is in control
there
well this is a war gearheart neither
side wanting to concede defeat until
they absolutely have to as we know
russian president vladimir putin is
claiming victory over murray uphol
but the ukrainians don't agree vladimir
putin really does need a victory to take
home to the russian people on day 58 of
this war or special operation as it is
referred to back in russia and this is
perhaps the victory that he's looking
for the ukrainians saying that mario
paul still hasn't completely fallen
because there are still fighters those 2
000 fighters from the azov battalion and
the 36th marine battalion hiding out in
that as of steel plant as you've just
reported and also some civilians under
there as well they're well fair very
worried about by the ukrainian side uh
so you know that tit for tat will go on
until
russia is able to take that as of steel
plant which is expected to happen at
some stage yesterday we know that they
uh changed tactics on how they were
going to try and do that president putin
ordering the halting of the bombardment
of that steel plant instead trying to
blockade the area so that not even quote
a fly should be able to pass out of
there so it remains to be seen when just
how long it will take russia to
completely
complete their mission there and take
all of mariupol but at this stage
ukraine holding out
and also there are new uh reports here
of uh suspected mass graves near
mariupol visible on satellite images
what can you tell us about that
yeah shocking reports in mario poll of
some 20 000 people potentially killed of
course that number could be a lot higher
the mayor has said given that figure of
twenty thousand he's also said that
russians are going around trying to hide
the evidence collecting bodies and
taking them to a nearby cemetery and
dumping them in mass graves we're also
hearing reports of mobile crematoriums
so literally burning the evidence
they're very hard to verify that
information obviously as access into
mariupol is
almost well completely impossible in
fact
but we have seen those maxa satellite
images as you just heard in that report
that do appear to show those mass graves
out in that area near the cemetery
given what we've seen on the outskirts
here of kiev as the russian soldiers
retreated other mass graves other hiding
of dead bodies it is definitely
plausible and likely
dw correspondent rebecca richards there
speaking to us earlier and now we can go
straight to constantine egert he's our
russian expert and joins us from the
lithuanian uh capital vilnius
constantine uh putin has claimed victory
in mario paul uh most analysts and even
his own advisers say that's a bit
premature
what's really driving putin here
well putin after nearly two months of
this campaign which was supposed to last
just a few days
putin still has to present some kind of
decisive victory that could be
explainable uh to the russian people
especially on the eve of the day 9th of
may
which which is made into the main sort
of state holiday in russia by putin and
i think that mariupol claiming mariupol
even if he doesn't control it completely
uh is important
you can then say that russia now has a
more or less secure land corridor
between the occupied crimean peninsula
and the international recognized
territory of the russian federation i
think this is what drives putin to
announce
so in the early days of the war we saw
at least some protests across russia
that appears to have completely vanished
what happened is everyone in support now
of this war
well gareth
let's let's say that they were not mass
they were frequent and had the very wide
geography which which is important
uh but um by now
there are still protests you get every
day you get dozens of reports of the
people putting out leaflets against the
war or standing in pickets in front of
administrative buildings but one has to
understand uh since the this war the
second phase of putin's war was launched
on the 24th of february um the
government
and enacted quite a few uh very harsh
laws regarding fines and imprisonment
from mentioning this as a war it's
called special operation in russia so uh
people get imprisoned people get huge
fines and i think that that's timid the
the protests i mean that's quite natural
people are afraid for themselves and for
their family
now vladimir putin is considered a
master of stagecraft and when you look
at putin's recent meeting with his
defense minister shoigu discussing mario
paul
what do you see what can we read into
that
well two things first of all shogus
showed up not in in a military uniform
but in a suit uh maybe to fit putin
maybe just to indicate that yes uh happy
holidays the war is very soon over and
secondly that is what is being massively
discussed now on uh on russian
twittersphere which i followed uh it's
put in state of health because everyone
um
everyone saw that putin is clutching at
the table his right arm is constantly
clinging at the table edge some people
say that could be an attempt to control
hand tremors which may indicate
parkinson's disease but of course
we're not doctors and speculations about
putin's health have been going on for
quite some time now he's still
commanding the operation he's still
tormenting your friend
tw correspondent constantine there thank
you constantine
thank you